الغطس البارد او حمام الماء المثلج انتشر
مؤخرا كتحد على التيك توك وشارك فيه من
المشاهير لها عبر مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي
وهو نظام تدريبي اصبح شائعا ضمن العنايه
البدنيه خاصه بعد ترويج العديد من
الرياضيين له كوسيله تسرع تعافي العضلات
بعد التدريبات الشاقه ليس فقط الرياضيين
من ينصحون بحمام الماء للمثلج لكن يشير
باحثون من جامعه بورناموس الى ان السباحه
في الماء البارد مفيده لصحه الدماغ وتقليل
التوتر رغم كل هذه الدعايه يظل هذا
الممارسه والتي تقوم كثير من الشعوب
بالقيام بها سواء في دول اسيويه كاليابان
وكثير من الدول الاوروبيه الى انها تظل
مثيره للجدل مع تحذيرات من خطر على مرضى
القلب بعيدا عن هذا الجدل سنذهب الى روسيا
مع مراسلنا عبد الجواد الرشد الذي سيقوم
بهذه التجربه مباشره
[موسيقى]
يقسم الكثير من من يمارس هذه السباحه في
المياه المتجمده على فوائد هذه الرياضه
الصحيه كثير منهم يعتبرونها رياضه لكن
عامه الناس يرون فيها احد انواع فنون
الجنود يعني لنشاهد هذا المشهد هذه هي
مجموعه من سباحي المياه المتجمده في موسكو
يعني هي مؤسسه رسميه مسجله لدى الاتحاد او
اللجنه الاولمبيه الروسيه كما نشاهد يعني
درجه حراره المياه هي الان تقترب من الصفر
والاحساس العام بالجو يقترب من ناقص 10
درجات هتختص ولا لا غيرت رايك دير بالك
على المايك يا عبد الجواد
مصر يعني يا ليث ما هيك لا لسه
خايف على المايك طبعا لابد يعني من تجربه
هذا الشيء يعني طيب يلا انا معكم ليش
تسمعني لاني راح اشيل السماعه لذلك بدي
منك بدي منك يا ليث ويا سمر تعدوا على
التنازلي من الخمسه عشره تسعه ثمانيه سبعه
سته خمسه اربعه ثلاثه
اثنين واحد تفضل
مباشره في صباح العربيه عبد الجواد الرشد
يقفز في مياه بارده اتصل
معاه بس شوفوا كيف حركه الجسم مهمه راسا
اول ما نط بدو يلعبوا يتناولوا الطابه
الكره
[موسيقى]